>>Sparky: Android Developer Relations Office
Hours.
I'm Sparky in Munich Germany and I'm joined
by my colleagues Rich, and Nick and Matt in
London UK.
>>Rich: Hi there.
>>Sparky: And we're here to talk to you about
any and all issues related to the development
of android applications.
So with that, maybe Rich would like to deliver
his famous disclaimer which he does so well.
>>Rich: [laughs] At the start of every android
developer office hours, we like to inform
the viewers who are currently zero, that—
[laughter]
>>Rich: Unless you're watching this later
on YouTube.
That we won't be discussing any feature, future,
future features, roadmaps, or suchlike.
Is that--??
[laughter]
Concise enough for you?
This is a Development Office Hours.
We're here to answer technical questions on
android.
Just discuss, we can talk about things like
the week's news.
And android features.
But nothing that hasn't been announced or
released.
[pause]
[Hangout dings]
>>Sparky: Does anybody have anything that
they would like to bring up before we start
trying to drive the discussion in any particular
direction?
[woman's voice in background]
>>Yossi: Hi guys.
>>Sparky: Hey Yossi, how are you?
>>Yossi: Fine.
>>Sparky: By the way, we have a question waiting
for you.
>>Yossi: For me?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Yossi: OK.
>>Sparky: But go ahead.
What's on your mind?
>>Yossi: I'm having difficulties with Google
API console.
Uh, we're trying to do twelve-hour application.
Through the Google API console so we can do
an OAuth on all android clients and so on.
And, I've tried to contact some people on,
few people on Google about it.
There's a bug in the console.
And I would like to see if you can help us.
It's quite urgent.
Yeah.
And if you want I can do a screen sharing,
for a few seconds.
>>Rich: Well, I've already, I've already seen
this issue, you know.
Yeah.
I think you sent it on to someone in Google
[unintelligible] hour, and they forwarded
it on to me.
And I forwarded it on to the people from the
API console team.
And I will chase them down [mumbles]
>>Sparky: Yeah, that's, it's a really interesting
concern.
And it's something that we bump into from
time to time too.
But it's not really in our core competency
either.
>>Yossi: Yeah, OK.
So, if you know, how can I check when this
issue will be resolved or something like,
restored?
Or maybe you can guide me through a, I don't
know, a breakthrough,over through, I don't
know where to through myself.
[laughs] Whatever you wanna, to call it but
I need to resolve this issue quite urgently.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Yossi: It will affect not only us, it will
affect everyone.
Cause we can't use our key store.
On the console.
And that's a big issue for us to list.
>>Sparky: Yeah, the, if I understand correctly,
the story for OAuth on the device is a little
bit different than it is for example on a
web app.
My only direct exposure to OAuth 2 is actually
doing it on the server side.
Like, if, in an app engine app.
And there it more or less works as described.
But even then, even then, following all the
tutorials and everything, it's completely
mind bending.
I get a headache every time I think about
it.
[laughter]
>>Yossi: Me too.
Me too.
I'm working on it like a week and trying to
see if we can get an override or some sort.
And be able to deliver, a feature that works
even though we don't have the console ready
for us.
My main concern is currently I'm using an
anonymous access to the API so, Google, I'm
showing a webview to the user.
While showing to the user the webview, I'm
getting a simple, you know, a big screen with
all the details about login and everything.
It's a simple webpage but the main concern
it says "Third party access and application
running on your computer is trying to access
your contact data."
And so on and so on.
Is there any possibilities to show a different
webview to the user, at least for the, until
the problem is resolved?
That's the main concern.
If not then we'll hold them and wait until
we can deal with that issue.
>>Sparky: That's a good question.
I just don't know.
Have you, now, you said you're doing anonymous
access.
Have you tried using, rather than doing the
full OAuth 2 have you tried just simple API
key?
Is that a possibility for you?
>>Yossi: No, Cause we can't use our key store
in the API console so we can't issue an API
key.
That's a problem.
If we were able to issue an API key, then
I wouldn't show the webview.
I would use the account manager on ICS devices
and forward, cause they issued the, the account
manager issues the OAuth token and then we
show the allow screen.
Default to the allow screen.
And if now, before ICS we just allow and we
show a dialog requesting their permission.
And using the—
>>Sparky: couldn’t you take an API key that's
issued to your application and just put it
statically in the app?
>>Yossi: Uh.
>>Sparky: I don't know.
I'm asking cause I haven't tried this.
>>Yossi: [laughs] No, the problem is that
I can't issue an API key.
That's the main issue.
From the point store.
And also I'm about using the, maybe I can
use the credentials from the webservice we're
using?
And try to manipulate that to be our also
as an authenticator or?
If it's, the main concern here is not to break
all the guidelines and conventions while using
the OAuth.
And we don't want to manipulate the user.
Or fake—
>>Rich: So you've just encountered a bug with
something that's affecting your account.
I wouldn't say it's worth investing time to
invent a workaround.
>>Yossi: OK.
>>Rich: That should be resolved soon.
I've just seen, just right now a thing that
[unintelligible] an update of the issues.
So we'll get back to you real soon.
>>Yossi: OK.
I see.
OK, so I had another question.
Regarding something else.
We have a response from the Google server.
Maybe not from Google serve, from any server.
We're having an XML file sent to me, and I'm
trying to do a stream reader input stream.
And a buffered reader.
And for some reason I always get the 24 last
bytes not readed from the stream.
I know the, it's something very very weird.
And I'm trying to figure out why.
And is there a specific API or a good example
for a buffered reader to see where we're doing
it wrong or something?
Cause I'm quite sure we have an issue on our
reader.
Cause other platforms read it OK.
And just wanted to make sure.
Something very very weird.
>>Al: Is that on a specific device or have
you seen it on multiple devices?
>>Yossi: I've checked on only two devices.
On the Nexus 7 and the Galaxy Nexus.
And on other devices, we, I think we all encountered
the same issue.
Cause the XML file, I'm reading in the stream
into chunks of eight K's and going with the
wild look on it.
But something is wrong and I'm not able to
read the last 24 bytes.
>>Al: And it's coming from a server via HTTP?
>>Yossi: Yeah, yeah.
Iris can read it.
Windows can read it.
And it's something very very weird.
Maybe you've encountered something like that.
>>Nick: Nope.
It sounds like a bug.
Can you post the, post that up on StackOverflow?
>>Yossi: Yeah, just thinking—
>>Al: Uh, the other thing I was wondering
is, whether it's worth trying to use the XML
pull paths to see if you're getting all of
the XML that way.
>>Yossi: OK.
That's the code I'm using.
Just to verify a few contacts.
It's just a char buffer and B reader is the
buffered reader from the input stream.
And append result is doing just the string
builder and doing append to the string builder.
And, trying to figure out why it's not working.
>>Al: And you've checked the contact length
is actually the right value for the data that's
being returned.
You're not being returned a "short contact"
link?
>>Yossi: Yes, yes, yes.
No, no.
I've checked it and the same request from
the server on IOS and Windows is working .and
only on our android devices it's not working.
And this code works on all requests but this
one.
And it's driving me crazy.
>>Sparky: Yeah, I could probably, let me see.
We could try to find the bug in the code but
I don't know if we wanna do that right now.
>>Yossi: Yeah, yeah.
Just asking if you have any examples for a
good example or guideline to follow to see
where this is going wrong?
Cause I want to change this code.
Cause if it's not working I want to rebuild
it or something.
I don't want to use it and make a faulty response
or something like that.
>>Al: Just off the top of my head, looking
at it.
>>Yossi: Yeah.
>>Al: You're using Ready from Buffered Reader?
That basically indicates whether the reader
is ready to be read from without blocking.
So it's potentially possible that you haven't
got enough data left to fill a block in the
buffer, and therefore the buffer is not ready
to read without blocking.
>>Yossi: Yeah, but if I, you see, I'm using
also Readit Total.
To count the bytes I've read to see if I need
to read more.
And while comparing it I see I have 24 bytes
left.
>>Al: But if the buffer in the buffered reader
is larger than 24 bytes, you may get false
return from Breader.ready.
because its' not ready to return a whole chunk
of data for you.
>>Yossi: But, BReader is supposed to return
"ready" if it has more bytes to read.
>>Al: No, no.
It's only supposed to return "ready" true
if it has more bytes that can be read without
blocking.
So if there's an implementation that requires
the buffer to be filled before it will return
the data to you, it can return false, even
though there's data semi filling the buffer.
Let me just post up the link to the java doc.
>>Yossi: Yeah, OK.
>>Al: There's a, it's down in the under the
hood implementation.
I think what you're confusing it with is "available.
Let me just have a—
>>Yossi: "Available" is not on the methods
for buffer gridder.
>>Al: What you might wanna do is, in your
"else" section of your ref, put it in something
to see if you can read an individual byte
from it.
Without getting an exception back.
>>Yossi: Oh.
OK.
I'll try that one.
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Yossi: OK.
I'll try it now and let you know if it works
or something.
>>Al: Cool.
>>Nick: I had an example of [unintelligible]
which is using while read returning [inaudible]
and zeros.
>>Yossi: OK.
Here is a snippet.
OK.
It's reading.
Also, see if it's now minus one.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Nick: Yeah.
That's the kind of thing I meant.
>>Yossi: OK.
I'll try both methods and see, and let you
know.
And also you had a question for me?
>>Rich: Sparky, you said something about having
a question.
>>Yossi: Sparky?
>>Rich: [unintelligible]
>>Sparky: You work on Oovoo, is that right?
>>Yossi: Sorry?
>>Sparky: You work on Oovoo?
>>Yossi: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Someone posted a question in the
Moderator saying "Why doesn't Oovoo work?"
>>Yossi: [laughs] I didn't see it.
I'll look into it.
But.
I know it's working 'cause I’m working at
Oovoo.
[laughs] No, I'll take a look at that.
>>Nick: Works in lab [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Sparky: Yeah, works in the lab.
>>Yossi: Yeah, it also works outside.
So.
>>Sparky: Oh, here we go.
"How come Oovoo doesn't work on HTC1X?"
>>Yossi: Oh, OK.
So that's the main issue we also have and
I think a lot of VOIP services has.
Because each device, each manufacturer has
their own implementation to the camera API.
Some of them don't use the exact API.
Cause we're basically assuming the camera
API from the stock android is working.
But sometimes on different devices when we
try to initialize the camera or try to work
with the camera, the device is not implementing
the correct API as we want it to be.
Or as we assume it to be.
So we just block the devices for now.
And that's a main issue we want, I wanted
to ask on further sessions.
How can we use our check or maybe get involved
with more cameras on devices?
Even though they don't have the full API implementation.
Cause we want to support more devices than
every, we want to support every device there
is out there but sometimes when we do our
testing, we see that the device doesn't support
flipping the camera or rotation.
Or maybe it's supporting lower resolution
than we want to allow our users to see.
Or maybe the basic API doesn't allow us to
get a hook on the camera and show it on surface—
[video cuts out]
>>Yossi: --appreciate it if all device manufacturers
will follow the API guidelines for the camera
and allow us to interact with the camera without
using different hooks and different pieces
of code to just support more and more devices.
>>Sparky: Yeah, that would be great.
Maybe—
>>Nick: You could also contribute CTS tests.
>>Yossi: Sorry, what?
>>Nick: I think the most pragmatic way to
approach that would suggest writing a pass
compatibility test.
>>Yossi: Yeah, yeah.
We looked into it but I think if we'll, propose
a test for the CTS suite, it will be a problem
for all devices out there.
Cause we have a very and vast list of devices
not implementing the whole API.
Or implementing the API not in a way we can
use that.
So what we'll do—
>>Sparky: That's exactly why we need to make
the CTS better.
>>Yossi: Yeah, but what will, do you, what
will you suggest to do with devices out there?
Just block them and say to users "OK, devices
are not ready to work and they will not work
until the end of dawn," I don't know.
>>Al: One of the things you can do, within
the android Open Source project, which is
where the compatibility test suite lives,
there's the Master Branch, which is the development
branch for future versions.
So you can handle all the current devices
as you're currently handling them.
And put your CTS test into the master branch
so future versions can benefit from it.
>>Yossi: OK, but mainly the main issue is
here that people like, I don't know HTC, Samsung,
they take the main branch and then they work
on their own branch.
>>Al: Well, the CTS is held by Google.
They can work on their own customizations.
But the CTS is the standard.
I mean, the guys in London and Sparky will
tell you, they're battering up on this.
The CTS is the standard which Google set in
order to get approval to get the Google app
suite.
>>Yossi: OK.
>>Al: So they can take the core of android,
mess around with it.
But they still have to pass the CTS.
>>Yossi: So if they don't pass our tests in
it for the camera, they won't be certified
to the—
>>Nick: They won't get PlayStore or GoogleMaps,
or Gmail or anything like that.
>>Yossi: That's better, that's better.
That's a good one.
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Basically, the strength of a platform
is as good as the CTS makes it.
>>Nick: Yeah, so it's going to help you get
the current crop of devices out there.
And you may have to do some device specific
stuff for when manufacturers have done strange
things.
But it's a pragmatic approach.
The only way to improve the situation in the
future is to strengthen the tests.
>>Yossi: OK.
Thanks a lot guys.
>>Al: And if you do that for the camera you
will be a bit of a hero.
Cause I know you're not the only person facing
this kind of problem
>>Yossi: [laughs] Yeah, we have a lot of tests
we're doing, to see if each device has all
the API we require.
And we do a lot of app testing to see if it
works.
And it will be much more, it will be easier
to us to handle devices that fully implement
the API and we can—
>>Nick: huh.
Someone muted Yossi.
[Hangout dings]
>>Rich: No one was muting him.
[laughs] Why is Yossi mute?
>>Sparky: Alright, well.
[laughter and comments]
>>Yossi: Can you hear me?
>>Matt: Yay.
>>Sparky: We can hear you now.
>>Yossi: OK.
Everybody's muting me.
I don't know why.
But.
[laughter]
Yeah, I know you're sick of hearing me.
>>Nick: I think you've had us [unintelligible]
far too long.
>>Yossi: Yeah.
Yeah.
I'll finish by saying thank you to all.
I'll mute myself and allow other people to
ask more questions.
Thank you.
>>Sparky: Cool.
Thanks a lot Yossi.
It was really good of you to contribute to
the discussion.
Would anyone else like to step forward with
a question or an issue they wanna talk about?
>>Matt: I think Steven had one but it got
removed this end when we had a bit of a crash.
>>Rich: He was asking the best recommendations
for implementing MVC in android applications.
>>Matt: that was the one.
>>Rich: Was that right?
Stephen?
Can we get a nod?
>>Matt: Yep.
>>Rich: Yup.
If we can't get a nod, you can type.
That's OK.
Oh, yes.
Android forces you into MVC in many ways.
With having your activities as your controllers
and the views as your XML files.
Having your data provided through content
providers anyway.
So if you just follow kind follow kind of
standard android paradigms you fall into MVC
rules pretty quickly.
Was there anything specific around that, Stephen?
Any specific questions around MVC and android?
Or is that kind of--.
Have you been doing android development for
a long time?
Or are you new to--?
Stephen says "Give me two."
OK.
We'll just—
>>Sparky: I would say, if you really wanna
take that a step further, you do the, do your
M behind a content provider so that you have
a nice clean interface to your model.
>>Nick: Definitely.
Yeah.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Alright Stephen.
We'll hold for your question until you've
got a webcam and can actually ask it live.
In the mean time we've got loads of questions
in the Moderator this week.
So let's take a look over.
>>Matt: This guy.
[laughs]
>>Rich: This guy.
We should show you once.
>>Sparky: You know, I'm just a little bit
amused because I just looked at a question
in android developers earlier today where
I think somebody wanted, sort of wanted to
go the opposite way.
He wanted to have different activities be
able to read each other's data numbers.
And I said "No, don't do that!"
[laughter]
Let's see.
"There's a serious memory leak in MapView
that causes when you scroll a map in one direction
for some time.
It's not yet solved and the first bug submission
was three years ago.
Is there any hope for this?"
Yes.
There is always hope.
Never give up hope.
Keep on reporting those bugs.
Star the issues to make sure they float to
the top.
Keep after us.
And yeah, don't, when an issue is important,
don't let us forget it.
We have other—
>>Nick: But I guess that falls into the category
of you know, commenting on future releases.
Which we're not really gonna be able to do,
unfortunately.
So, yeah, keep on starring the bugs.
But we're not gonna be able to say "Yes, a
fix is coming!" or anything like that.
>>Sparky: Right.
And I would just like to remind people that
the top starred issue for a long time was
native support for Arabic in android.
And eventually we got it.
So keep at it.
>>Matt: The system works.
>>Nick: System works.
[Hangout dings]
>>Sparky: Let's see, what else do we have?
"Is it possible to detect which audio and
video formats are returned by the default
camera application when you record a video
via the intent?"
That was kind of a tricky one.
I imagine there might be a way, but I just
said "Most users will never change it.
So just capture one once and see what you
get."
>>Rich: Sorry, which question was he on?
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Rich: The "is it possible to [unintelligible]
format?"
>>Matt: Yep.
>>Rich: That would [mumbles] . So, in Jellybean
it is.
I'm not sure about previous versions of android.
In Jellybean you can use the MediaCodec class
to inspect the video and it will tell you
the audio and video formats that have come
back.
We have some sample code at the top of the
MediaCodec documentation at developer.android.com.
which would tell you the format of the video.
You can use it to inspect any video file on
your device.
>>Nick: [inaudible]
>>Rich: Or a new file.
It light up and it will tell you the encoding,
the bit rates, anything about that video file.
You can also transport them as well.
With our file, which is good.
>>Nick: Beyond that I'm not sure.
You might have to use an external library,
some kind of mpeg or something like that might
be able to, and try and load it.
And, take some more metadata about it.
But before Jellybean, yea, you might be able
to—
>>Rich: Before Jellybean FF mpeg is quite
a common, libraries use.
You've got video processing inside android.
Everything else has gone very very quiet like
our speakers are turned off or something.
Is everyone else still there?
>>Al: Yep.
[laughter]
>>Sparky: They're on the edge of their seats.
They're listening with rapt attention as we
work our way through the Moderator questions.
>>Rich: Ah.
So we've got Stephen now?
Stephen is back.
Has he got a view?
Which one—
>>Matt: There we go.
>>Rich: Hey Stephen.
Can you talk as well, do you have audio?
>>Stephen: Yeah, hopefully, if this mic thing
works.
>>Rich: It does, it's fine.
>>Stephen: Does it?
Right.
So your first question was how long have I
been developing?
Since G1.
>>Rich: Nice.
DO you still have your G1?
>>Stephen: I do, yes.
In a box.
[laughter]
So, yes.
>>Nick: I saw someone who got Jellybean running
on the G1.
And apparently it's all [unintelligible]
[laughter]
>>Stephen: So right.
My real question is about whether or not you
should use MVC as a pattern for android.
Whether it's applicable.
So we work across a lot of platforms.
Looking at trying to get some kind of platform
implementation that we could use for our products
across-- Blackberry phone.
Maybe iPhone.
And, and, MVC doesn't really seem to fit,
to me.
I'm struggling to find a way that would allow
us to do what we wanna to do.
In a way that doesn't totally break android.
>>Nick: Which place doesn't it fit?
>>Stephen: Um, so, wow.
Talk about a programmer using [unintelligible].
We write payment software.
Like GoogleWallet, that kind of thing.
So we have sort of defined flows.
Things that we have to do.
So we wanna be able to provide a library and
a framework and sort of a navigation controlling
stack that says, if you gotta enter your PIN
you have to follow this flow 'cause that's
the specified thing.
Which is fine in Blackberry and probably in
other platforms but the way we're looking
at doing it now it seems like it would kind
of circumvent all the niceness of android.
You know, the activities and the intent stacks
and all of that jazz.
So I'm looking for a bit of advice.
>>Rich: Is it, across, to break it out into
individual activities?
Have you considered building the whole app
in one activity?
Or--?
>>Stephen: It will be across multiple activities.
The way we've got many of the sort of the
current things, we have like a navigation
controller.
That knows where you need to go next and will
deal with say, pulling things out of the backstack.
So if you have to PIN verify to get to a piece
of the application, when you go back, you
don't want to go back to the PIN verification
screen.
Cause that's dumb.
So that needs to be sort of pulled out.
So that's all that is mainly.
Doesn't seem like we need to do that in android
so I can set some intent flags and that and
they'll turn up on the history.
So, do the developers look at this.
They're not android guys.
So any, I'm trying to find, I guess ammunition,
I don't know, educational material, to try
and maybe steer us in a better direction than
what we're using right now.
Cause it doesn't, it seems like we're going
'round a lot of what android gives us.
That feels like it's gonna break things later.
Like we're kind of going to end up with a
single controller per activity, breaks the
use of fragments, like, how can?
I don't really know how to explain that to
people who are familiar with how android's
built.
>>Rich: It's a shame that you've got android
development that aren't really with android.
It seems you've got there.
So.
>>Stephen: They're not android developers,
the guys working on this.
So we work from everything down from C all
the way up to android.
>>Rich: Sure.
>>Stephen: So, the low level stuff is C. Uh
I think we'll be doing [unintelligible] in
like a base java implementation.
>>Rich: So we have a lot of documentation
at developer.android.com.
Have they all at least been through the basic
documentation on activities and activity life
cycles?
Things like that?
And how, the five main parts of an android
app and how they're all put together?
Intents, activities, broadcast receivers,
that kind of thing?
Services?
>>Stephen: Yeah, so they're aware of that.
And it seems like you could, you could, feels
like shoehorn in MVC into it.
So when the activity launches you know, you
could register against a custom application
object to get a control [burr].
That would then handle this logic.
But that doesn't, that doesn't feel right
to me.
>>Nick: Yeah, it's not going to be good trying
to shoehorn them into using something that's
not android native, but I've been 'round this
as well, like, a lot of the times when you
try and use any of these frameworks like dependency
injections and so on, you end up sacrificing
you know, writing the application the android
way.
So you take advantage of these things like
intents, and you know doing things in the
most memory efficient way.
You end up using a lot of reflections and
passes and so on and so forth.
>>Stephen: Yeah.
>>Nick: So the general best advice I guess
is to try and write native what you can, like
try and adopt a native android paradigm.
So you get this taking, I guess the disadvantage
then is that you have a different flow to
your android app than you might have to your
other applications but that'll almost inevitably
end up being a better application, I'd say.
>>Stephen: Yes, that's my opinion as well.
I was hoping that, I was hoping to [unintelligible]
maybe some more experience or some more online
documentation of people trying to use MVC.
And I had a bit of a Google around, and there's
a couple of StackOverflow's, things.
Which are basically like, "Well, you could
probably do it like this.
Sort of."
Seems to become the route we're heading down.
What I don't want to do is, uh—
>>Nick: Well I think you've nailed the issue
on the head that you end up not taking advantage
of all the android things like intents and
so on and so forth.
You end up kind of steamrolling over those.
So, yeah, you're gonna end up with a worse
app in many ways
>>Stephen: Yeah.
So here's a possible concrete question.
If, so, we've got our controller, right?
Which is apparently gonna have a reference
to the activity.
If we move off that activity to a new one,
can we use the label "call destroy" on the
one that's been paused.
>>Nick: Can you manually call destroy?
>>Stephen: Yeah.
>>Rich: You call finish on it if you wanna
kill it off.
It should finish itself.
If you really need to it can call finish on
itself and then it'll run the destroy.
>>Al: OK, you wanna chalk around that, a good
word thing is using a broadcast intent or
a directed intent.
Back to the first activity.
So you register a broadcast intent listener
in your activity.
That waits for a specific intent to be broadcast
and then will finish itself once it receives
that broadcast.
>>Nick: Not a bad idea.
Yeah, and you can use a local broadcast for
that activity, but [unintelligible] system
broadcast as well.
>>Stephen: OK.
I've got concerns about us trying to manually
manage the activity history when that’s
already being controlled by the OS.
>>Nick: Yeah, it sounds like you're duplicating
a lot of what, you know, the OS is all about.
>>Stephen: To me, to me it sounds like a terrible
idea.
But—
>>Al: You can also get into memory problems
when you're trying to keep references to other
activities.
It, it's a road to hell.
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Stephen: Yeah, exactly.
So at the moment we've got like, an activity
with some UI and a controller, and it's like
yeah, this kind of works.
So.
>>Sparky: It sounds to me, it sounds to me
like you're maybe facing a little bit of a
pitfall in trying to attach your business
objects and logic to activities.
I mean, it seems to me like maybe what you
want is, you want an object with some kind
of a state flow diagram that controls the
different phases.
The different states that your object goes
through as the different activities manipulate
it.
Maybe you wanna attach that to a service.
And then use, you know, have your activities
present the user interface.
But have them using intents to send messages
to the service.
Or a published API.
And then let the service control the lifecycle
of your actually sort of abstract business
object.
>>Stephen: Yeah, that's, that's more or less
what I've done.
So I've, it's always what we've, you know,
we're looking to sort of unify a lot of stuff.
So the android stuff I've written is basically
runs like that.
So the services are the brains.
And I'm basically, I'm raising like intents
to say "I wanna do a PIN, and I need to do
this."
And the activity is shown.
And you know, so yeah it does that, but it's,
the, I think, I'm getting rolled under the
wheels of cross-platforms.
Yeah.
I think.
I might just have to lump it.
>>Sparky: Hmm.
I would think that coding up a service would
actually be like the most translation that
you could get of your C based native implementations
from other platforms anyway.
Wouldn't it?
>>Stephen: Yeah, I think so.
So I mean, so the stuff we're currently porting
is based on a Blackberry implementation.
So that's, I mean, Blackberry you can do kind
of what you like it seems.
In terms of just making objects and moving
things around.
So it's, I think we're just kinda trying to
quickly port the business object from that
onto the android UI stuff.
And I don't think it's really gonna work.
>>Al: "Quickly" is one of those business terms
that never ends up with a good technical solution.
Unfortunately.
>>Stephen: Yeah, exactly.
I've, I've don't know what I'd call it, it's
very kind of "Proto-duction."
[unintelligible]
>>Nick: IT's always quicker to write the correct
solution in the long run.
So you write the quick one and end up having
to go back and fix it, where I find it in
[inaudible]
>>Stephen: Yeah.
Seriously.
>>Nick: It's often quicker to just do it properly.
>>Stephen: Yeah.
Tell me about it.
Or rather, tell the sales guys.
I knew that already.
>>Al: Point them to the Facebook app, that'll
usually wake a few people as to the dangers
of trying to do something cross-platform.
>>Stephen: Yeah, it's nasty.
I'm also, I don't wanna tie up everyone's
hangout.
So I can stop if people have other questions.
>>Nick: So there was a massive question pasted
into the sidebar.
Who sent it?
Go back up.
Raphael.
>>Raphael: Yeah.
Hi guys.
That's a question from me.
>>Sparky: Hi.
>>Rich: Hey.
>>Raphael: so basically, it's the simple question,
I have two questions.
So the question is, I use location in my application
ad I use different providers like GPS and
network provider.
Depending on visibility and other stuff.
But I just tested the application on different
devices and I had a problem with devices that
don't have GPS built in.
so basically it's a simple question.
What combination of user's permission and
user's feature I should use to be available
to download and visible in the GooglePlay
devices without built-in GPS?
>>Sparky: Well there's always that "required
equals," is it "required equals false?"
Is that right, on the user's feature.
>>Nick: Yeah.
It's, he's got both permissions to find location
and post location, which is correct.
And then user's feature.
The location of network with "required equals
true" and then put a location on GPS with
"required equals false."
So yeah, your tightest consideration is that
you're requiring network location.
I don't know many devices which don't--.
>>Raphael: So, there won't be problem with
find location permission on this kind of devices
without GPS?
>>Matt: So which devices are you having problems
with?
>>Raphael: I have one tester with some strange
Chinese tablet that don't have GPS built in.
and unfortunately I don't have any other devices
without GPS.
But I want to be able to unload on—
>>Matt: Does the tablet have a SIM Card slot
in it as well?
>>Raphael: Yeah.
>>Matt: Yeah, it definitely does?
>>Raphael: So, you think from the screen,
like it should work?
>>Rich: Yeah, this is what I would have recommended
that you used.
You've got the right permissions and the right
access.
The right features.
>>Nick: If you upload the APK to pubsites,
[unintelligible] site.
And the supported device pile should tell
you which devices you're filtering out with
your requirements, right?
>>Raphael: Yeah, so thank you guys.
And I have another question.
It's more strange and complicated.
So I used view pager on one of my fragment
activities.
And basically it have five fragments inside
it.
On the portrait, on the smart phones and on
the portrait on the tablets, but when I use
it on the landscape or on the tablet, I want
it to be for fragments inside, for ViewPager.
So basically the problem is that I don't really
understand how the ViewPager holds the orientation
change and what states is it saving by itself.
So it looks like it's not deleting or detaching
fragments when I rotate on tablet.
Because on create, I create new fragment adapter
and populate it with four or five fragments
but it looks like it's not deleting or detaching
fragments on destroy or something like that.
So, do you know what's the lifecycle of ViewPager?
And how I can populate dynamically with you
know, with fragments.
Adding them, maybe.
Or deleting completely before rotation changes.
>>Rich: So the thing I would do to check it
quickly is the source for the support libraries
available on your computer already.
And the source for the ViewPager isn't actually
that big.
You can go and have a look at the lifecycle
methods inside it pretty quickly.
It's just in your android SDK under "Extras",
Google Supporter something.
Under that is Source and [V4].
And you can just have a quick look through
there and have a look at the source and see
the life cycles for it.
I know that there's two different fragment
ViewPages.
There's the "saving state" one.
And a non-saving state one.
>>Nick: Uh, adapters.
>>Rich: Sorry, the fragment—
>>Nick: Adapters
>>Rich: Adapter for the ViewPager.
So, potentially the non-saving state one is
gonna zap everything on rotation.
But I would have to look.
>>Raphael: So there is a special adapter or
ViewPager for not saving state.
>>Nick: There's one ViewPage and there's two
different adapters, right?
There's, oh, you're probably looking at docs
right now, yeah?
What the two classes that extend fragment
adapter?
>>Al: Let me have a look.
One of the things I was looking at was wondering
whether you're in the fragment, you've got
any reference back to the context.
Are you storing the context in the object?
>>Raphael: Yeah, maybe.
>>Al: You should, if you're storing a reference
to the context, that'll keep it in memory,
so that'll make it wanna get cleared out.
>>Raphael: Oh.
OK.
Yeah.
>>Al: Which'll probably be a problem.
>>Raphael: I thought about it.
Yeah.
So that's what I used.
This one.
Yeah, now I understand why everything, not
anything working.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for this.
>>Rich: Yeah.
OK.
Right.
>>Nick: You've got the fragment pager adapter
and the fragment state pager adapter.
So—
>>Raphael: So basically what is the difference
between them.
Like, I know that the state adapter won't
load the newest, next adapter as a, as I think.
>>Nick: Yeah.
So they're built for two different things.
They're basically ViewPager doesn't really
do view recycling.
So the non stateful one, so the stateful one.
So if you're going through a very long list
of pages, you know, you're gonna end up with
memory problems.
Cause it's not doing any management of it.
So it's' for different kind of circumstances.
So if you have like say, four tabs which you're
paging between, then you use the stateful
one.
If you want to be able to like go through
a list of items and you don't wanna be saving
states you're gonna end up racking up loads
of fragments.
>>Raphael: OK.
Thank you guys.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Nick: You're welcome.
>>Rich: And if it doesn't work, check the
source.
[laughter] [inaudible] android.
OK.
Sparky, have you been having a look at the
Moderator?
>>Nick: Yeah, I recommend, everyone should
read the source on ViewPagers.
It's really cool.
[laughter]
I was looking at it the other day and that's
how I learned that you could do bezel swiping
built in on ViewPager [inaudible].
>>Rich: Right.
ViewPager gets updated with every version
of the support IP, pretty much.
Most of the features.
How you can add margins between the pages.
Change the width of pages now.
Bezel swiping.
ViewPager got more powerful.
>>Sparky: Alright.
So should we take one from the Moderator?
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Alrighty.
The next one that I have in the moderator
is, from Flowers.
"With the notification, only the icons and
ticker text are public members of the object.
Useful fields like content title, content
text, and the inbox text fields only exist
in the remote view created and are not easily
accessible.
Is this for security?"
I would say probably not.
It's probably more for extensibility.
I'm, I'm just sort of going out on a limb
her and guessing that you know, in the first
go around of an API, there's a tendency to
make a few things public and then as the API
grows you realize that it's gonna be harder
and harder to give people access to these
public members and then you start creating
methods to access them.
That's my guess.
But I don't actually know so if anybody knows
different, by all means, chime in. and let
us know what you think.
[hangout dings]
OK.
>>Rich: No.
No.
I don't know any different.
>>Nick: So I didn't understand the question.
He's trying to read other people's notifications
or when you create your own notification object.
I didn't know how to [mumbles].
I would say, if it is trying to read other
people's notifications then it's security.
>>Rich: It's security.
Definitely.
>>Nick: Yeah, I know that some people try
and get around that using the assist but,
so—
>>Rich: Yeah.
OK.
What's the next one Sparky?
>>Sparky: Hm.
"I've been trying to code a camera related
app.
However, when I try to start preview, the
emulator camera seems to always crash.
Running the official camera app produces a
moving square but the buttons were unresponsive.
Is this expected?"
Ummm.
Not really ever expected in the emulator is
it?
I don't know.
>>Al: It could be that there's not enough
memory been allocated when the virtual device
was created.
I've seen that happen.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
>>Nick: Well, I would probably say, check
LogCat as well.
I mean, it's not just going to crash and not
tell you why.
So we kind of, it's only half the story.
We need to know what LogCat's saying.
You definitely having a preview on screen?
Or do you need to have surface allocated to
preview, which is on the screen?
In order for the preview functions to work?
>>Rich: So.
If you're around, come in and we'll come to
the thread and we'll add you in so you can
come and add more detail to the question.
>>Sparky: One thing that I did once when I
was trying to test an app that used photo
intents, was rather than using the built in
camera app, I wrote myself a teeny teeny tiny
little app that actually caught that intent
and just sent back an image that I had stored
on my file system.
Which was kind of an interesting learning
exercise.
I hope to put up that code as a sample code
sometime.
I thought that was sort of an interesting
alternative to, rather than using any built
in camera app, I just wrote my own.
And all it does is return a file.
>>Nick: That would be good for testing.
>>Sparky: Yeah, it was also quite revealing
to learn just exactly how to pack that data
into the intent for a return.
I was, you know, I never knew before I sort
of couldn't figure out how it was down.
And I, it took me a while to actually wrap
my head around exactly how that needed to
be sent back.
>>Nick: Huh.
Then you should definitely open source it.
>>Sparky: Yeah.
I hope to have it in the, like the second
generation of the camera sample app that goes
into android training.
>>Matt: Cool.
>>Sparky: Should we, does anyone have something
in the hangout or should we go on to the next
Moderator question?
>>Male #1: I have a question.
>>Sparky: Hi, go ahead.
>>Male #1: So I should, I added a moderator
question too, but the question has to do with
the animation framework.
And basically I wanna implement having a fragment
off screen.
Click a button and it would slide on screen
and adjust the size of all the widgets views
that are there.
So I was looking at the animation shortcut
string long function.
And I can definitely move things around but
the question is, how do I get the initial
offset to be zero or below the actual container
view that I have?
>>Nick: Aright, to get the offset, to make
it start offscreen?
>>Adam: Right.
Kind of like how the sliding drawer does,
like in the old app launcher.
So basically, you click a button, it'd slide
in, and then click another button, it'd slide
out.
So kind of like a menu or something like that.
>>Nick: So you could just set it's left property
to the negative of the width of the button.
>>Adam: OK, and so and then I would click
the button and then I would just adjust it
to the animate feature?
>>Nick: Yeah, and animate it from that value.
[loud background noise]
[hissing feedback]
>>Nick: That make sense?
>>Rich: Oh, we've lost you Adam.
You appear to have been muted as well.
>>Adam: Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Um, you know, but that makes sense.
I'll give that a try.
>>Rich: Well, cool.
Huh.
OK.
>>Nick: Yeah.
One of the issues at hand, if you are using
the view.animate object.
Which returns your view property animator,
right?
It's really really nice and leads to some
very clean code.
But I think one of the drawbacks is you can
only animate one property at a time.
I don't think you can do animation sets though.
Is that right?
>>Adam: Maybe with different types, I think.
I don't know if you can do the same type.
But you can do different, translates and outputs.
>>Nick: That should be no problem for you.
>>Adam: OK.
Thanks.
>>Nick: Sure.
And if that's not working for you, then there's
a bunch of these fly in menu implementations
on GetHelp as well.
Which should hopefully, you know, you can
check one of those out, see how they do it,
as well.
[pause]
>>Rich: Alright.
Check the source ViewPager.
[chuckles]
>>Sparky: Alright.
Well that was great.
That was two birds with one stone we got a
Moderator question and a live question.
>>Matt: Boom.
How we roll.
>>Sparky: Anybody else?
Anyone else want to go two for the price of
one?
No?
Alright, let's see what else is on the Moderator.
Oh, that was Adam's question.
[pause]
"You guys misunderstood my one-by-one widget
question last week."
>>Nick: Oh, this is the configuration thing
we talked.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: "After a bit of searching, thought
of the proper name, are shortcuts.
And the intent is 'create shortcut.'
But can't figure out how you create one."
So.
Do we have samples for that?
Probably?
>>Rich: He's creating and application shortcut
on the desktop.
As opposed to a more [unintelligible] app.
OK?
>>Sparky: Seems to me like every commercial
app in the world that you download from the
PlayStore wants to install a desktop shortcut.
So it must be pretty well, there must be a
thousand tutorials that show how it's done.
I've never wanted to do it, so I don't know.
>>Al: I've come across the StackOverflow question
on it so I'll post that up.
Cause it's got a quite in depth answer to
the question.
>>Rich: We also have a StackOverflow question
on it as well.
StackOverflow is always a good resource for
these things.
We're on StackOverflow.
Android engineers also frequent StackOverflow
and answer questions there frequently.
>>Matt: So is it trying to do something similar
to like People where you wanna create a home
icon?
>>Rich: That's what I thought it was last
week.
>>Matt: Well, yeah you know with the contacts
app, you can create a one-by-one shortcut
via your home dashboard.
And do something like that.
That's specific to your app.
>>Rich: But he wants it to go through settings
on the way there, as well.
He said he'd specifically like settings.
A create law which first configures itself,
like the setting shortcut.
Maybe that's what, maybe he didn't see the
live view and only saw Sparky's answer.
The typed in answer.
>>Nick: It says setting shortcut.
>>Rich: Yeah, it was configuration.
It's when you drop it and it goes into widget
configuration.
>>Matt: We need some more input.
>>Rich: Even more input, please.
From Houdini.
>>Matt: Maybe we answered him.
>>Nick: Right.
So maybe he can watch—
>>Rich: [inaudible]
>>Nick: Well, goodness.
[laughter]
>>Rich: OK.
Da-da-da.
Anything else coming through?
If not.
>>Matt: No.
>>Sparky: Alright, shall we take the next
one?
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: "Hello, my android app to play an
audio stream works with Wi-Fi and a 3G data
card tested in US.
UK. India.
And on multiple devices.
But in a few cases it fails with the 3G card.
Should I resolve this by decreasing the quality
of the audio stream from the server."
Question mark.
>>Rich: What was the failure?
>>Sparky: I—
>>Rich: A failure that your bandwidth has?
>>Sparky: Who knows?
Yeah, I mean.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Sparky: I answered this one in mine, and
kind of said "Yeah, maybe."
You could try reducing the amount of data
by throwing out data before you compress it
or you can try a codec that compresses things
a little differently.
Maybe that, filters more aggressively.
Another thing I suggested is, it might not
just be a through put problem.
Might be a latency problem.
And that maybe you could also try changing
the size of the chunks of data that you're
sending.
If you're getting high pings, maybe send data
in bigger chunks at a time.
And so that the client can spend longer playing
while it waits for the new data to come in.
>>Rich: That's good advice, yeah.
>>Nick: It sounds like you basically wanna
implement, if that's a bit rate, streaming.
So you can either look at a protocol which
does that for you natively like HS, or you
could try and make something similar yourself.
By using the connectivity manager to check
the connection type that you have.
And then use that information to perhaps stream
a different quality source.
So, you're gonna need—
>>Rich: Maybe a quick bandwidth check as well?
>>Nick: Yeah, you wanna get that information,
really.
>>Sparky: What a brilliant answer.
I am so glad to work with people smarter than
me.
This is great.
[laughter]
OK.
Yes.
Adaptive bitrate.
I like it.
Make it so.
Let's see, the next question says "What's
the best way to implement a calendar functionality?"
Don't!
Use intents, or the content provider to talk
to the native calendar application and don't
implement your own.
That's my answer.
>>Nick: Or take the calendar of your source
and back port it.
>>Rich: Yeah, you can't.
[inaudible]
Well, you couldn't do.
It's just a bunch of actions.
>>Nick: No, no, he's trying to do calendar
view.
We're not talking about the calendar—
>>Rich: Oh, to implement that would—
>>Nick: It'd be [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Right.
I suppose you could always put it inside the
controller.
If you just want to—
>>Al: I'm guessing it would be something like
a flight or a holiday booking app, where they're
looking for something between two dates and
they wanna show a calendar as a method of
allowing people to pick the start and end
date.
>>Nick: Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah, and as of Honeycomb, we introduced a
nice little picker which will show these controls
and you can pick them up and down.
It's very nice to use.
But yeah, if you want that available pre-Honeycomb,
then you might be a bit stuck.
>>Sparky: Surely Jake Horton must have made
something.
>>Nick: I was gonna say, I've met 15 people
who have probably back ported it already,
if you go looking.
>>Sparky: Alright.
We have a couple new people in the hangout.
Dave just joined us.
Did you have anything on your mind?
IS there anything you wanna ask us or anything
you wanna talk about, android related?
>>Dave: I'm looking for a good podcast for
android development.
Something that will touch on all subjects
like java and, all that stuff.
I'm developing an app, but I can't, and I'm
kind of new at it.
I used to do some web development with PHP
and YSQL.
But I can't really find a good podcast that
comes out at least once a week or once every
couple of weeks and that's consistently updated
with good information.
>>Sparky: My first suggestion is go, look
for youtube/androiddevelopers.
Because that's where Android Devrol posts
all of the videos of our weekly hangouts.
>>Dave: Oh, OK.
Good.
>>Sparky: You will also get links to the talks
from Google IO.
>>Rich: I would do that.
Start with the 25 or whatever Android talks
from Google IO.
That will keep you busy until Christmas.
[laughter]
There's a whole bunch of information there.
And if you run out of those, go to the 2011
Google IO talks.
>>Sparky: Actually, you might even start with
the earlier ones.
Like start with the 2009, 2010.
Because those are the more basic android talks.
And by the time you get to 2011, 2012, you
don't get too many 100 level talks anymore
of the [inaudible].
>>Nick: Yeah, you have to have watched World
of Listview at least five times before you
call yourself an android developer.
Right?
>>Dave: OK, and just—
>>Al: But also, the live section of developers.google.com.
which has weekly shows.
And I believe Reto's making a Friday US, Friday
app session into a podcast that you can subscribe
to the feed for?
>>Nick: Is it just the Friday Clinic or is
it also the Office Hours as well?
I know he was turning it into a podcast.
>>Al: I'm not sure.
I'll have a quick look.
>>Nick: I think MotoDev do one as well, actually.
Did that once before.
I can't vouch for it, I didn't watch it for
very long.
>>Dave: Is that Model Dev?
>>Sparky: It's an android central, when fandroid
and android meet.
[unintelligible]
>>Nick: List developer [inaudible]
>>Dave: Well here's a quick follow up question.
So if I go back and start looking at the IO
talks from 2009, 2010, I've noticed during
some of my programming looking at texts and
stuff on line that some of the stuff is deprecated.
Is that gonna be true for some of those 2009,
2010 and even 2011 talks?
>>Rich: Oh, it's good to get the fundamentals
anyway.
It's certainly things like [unintelligible]
have changed a lot in that time.
And there'll be things that you're learning
that will get superseded by information in
the later talks.
>>Dave: Yeah, that's true.
>>Rich: A-lists came in.
Overage gyration came in.
Web views changed quite a lot.
So yeah.
There's gonna be things.
But it's good to understand the history, if
you've got time.
>>Dave: Yeah.
>>Sparky: And even though we deprecate, it's
a lot of times it's pretty gentle.
Like if you look in the documentation you'll
notice that settings activity is deprecated.
But it's only deprecated in favor of settings
fragment which works almost exactly the same.
And you can pretty much take your code from
the activity and plop it in the fragment and
it just about works.
>>Dave: Yeah, that's true.
>>Matt: [inaudible] deprecate.
And it'll probably point you in the direction
of what it's kind of been replaced with in
favor, so, it's still good just to know at
least where you're going.
And then documentations a pretty good point
you want to go next.
>>Sparky: Right, and also I would say, since
you say you're pretty new.
Don't be shy about asking questions in the
android developer's forum or on StackOverflow.
There's, and certainly, you can get really
good answers on StackOverflow.
Especially if you maybe do a quick search
and make sure that you haven't missed the
low hanging fruit.
>>Dave: Yeah.
>>Sparky: Cause sometimes they'll answer it
before you can even ask it.
>>Dave: Mm-hm.
>>Nick: OK.
I guess the one thing we should also mention
as well if you're trying to bootstrap your
android development is the android training
section on the developer's site.
So developer.android.com/training.
And those are, you know, a bunch of lessons
really which pull together individual training
docs.
So you know, while the reference documentation
is great, when you're trying to take a class.
How it works, what methods it has.
And actually you know, using a bunch of these
to build something useful.
That that's where training docs come in.
to string them all together.
So check those out as well.
>>Dave: OK.
Thanks.
>>Nick: You're welcome.
>>Rich: OK.
And with that we've actually hit three o'clock.
So that's the end of today's hangout.
Thank you all for joining us and asking questions
again.
And coming back.
Next week's hangout may be slightly different,
don't you think?
>>Nick: Oh yeah.
We're in Israel.
>>Yossi: Coming to us, no?
We have a meeting.
>>Rich: What's that Yossi?
>>Yossi: You're coming to Israel, right?
>>Rich: Yeah, we're gonna be in Israel next
week.
So look out for the hangout event.
As it may change time slightly.
>>Matt: I will be back, Sparky.
>>Rich: We'll try and get it scheduled.
So look out for the event.
>>Nick: And watch android developers for updates.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Alright.
See ya.
Thanks very much for coming.
>>Nick: Thanks for coming everyone.
>>Sparky: Bye guys.
>>Yossi: Bye guy.
See you soon.